what's going on there reject nation we are
going to start up today all of us are dead
the new korean zombie netflix series i don't know
yet what our upload schedule is going to be like
when the next episode comes out which i'm hoping
that we get this up every other day i'll have
something much more clear and precise i'm going
to expect these reactions to go up consistently
but yeah i mean we just finished watching the
kingdom finale that'll go up this weekend now
we're moving on to another korean zombie show
why not right loving loving the theme here i
see this being talked about a lot we even
put out a community post but this was worth
covering and then actually a lot of people were
like skip it and then when i was going through
comments i was realizing a lot of people who were
voting skip it i haven't even watched the show
so i was like okay there's something else this
community post is not reliable at all yeah but
we're interested so we figured why not let's check
it out uh if you can go ahead and hit that like
button that would be very much appreciated
also subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction for the
next all of us are dead is up as always full
length watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code for any show we cover is over at our
patreon page thanks to all of become superjects
by checking out all we got to offer over there
and the boys over prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights let's get to it people
emergency cross jesus
damn this guy's relentless a very convincing fight
get him
interesting so what's this
transformation process like
nothing a little jesus can't fix
oh my god
can a bible crush someone's head that kind
of book that's a pretty flexible bible
or is just symbolic [ __ ] oh my god did he infect
his kid with that in order to defend himself maybe
get out of there man
oh it's gonna be fun
that's a great dissolved
getting to know the layout of where
all the actions are going to take place
oh they'll be able to defend themselves
man i want to learn how to do archery
dead frog photo scorpion
metaphor symbolism in every frame
it's gonna be like a rat or something
oh what's gonna happen to this
little guy i don't know where
this is headed he's gonna start an outbreak
god
oh no god damn rat back up yeah put that
metal thing back on oh he was responsible
foreign
oh no he's figuring some [ __ ] out
he's writing in english collected parasitic
oh
like none of these kids get to class on time none
of the kids are eating breakfast i'm all rushing
i'm gonna go to school
green light so they're all trained runners
what a messed up school
oh no no no no
what the [ __ ] no come on carl
that's the weird part
oh it's messed up man
oh come on guys and were those two you passed
earlier the only two adults at the school
take your benzo what's this
guy's goal i don't know
is this an accident or is
this part of the plan which is
he should not do jack [ __
] about that what's going on
that radiator is coming off oh oh no she's got to
be making some noise right that could alert people
no
is she having a period
oh no please
holy balls
or she's just infected and i just
jumped up here that's what i did
cramps
or did you call the police about
the science teacher you had some
pretty big accusations coming out of her mouth
i've got to let him finish class first she went
no no they can't fall in love
what stop the spread of it well there's a
whole classroom of people who tell you people
who've been talking about it
i got you some socks
oh man that zombie's just gonna
want to make it right back to school
oh no so annoying
oh god
oh my god was that his bully
what the [ __ ] oh my god
oh man yeah that's not good
no god cut that arm off
why is it happening so faster
maybe it happens faster to adults
does this train to bassan
movie exist in this universe
does anybody know this issue how this works
i mean when shoot really hits the fan some of
these characters have to have seen a zombie movie
with great power
oh i hope you guys are the
first yeah rip them apart
use their faces
get him
nice
it begins and now let's get
someone over here to film you
cool
wow that was fast that's much faster
no
no school
this is why you should get homeschooled
oh no
no
no one notices her standing there internet
that's why
oh my god dude just just say yes loud and
proud there's still pedal what's wrong
let's go think those guys are on the roof man yeah
um
oh man
oh
ugh
it's real like psychedelic percolating
build to that's those tunes man yeah
because she's been bit too
oh maybe maybe he smells it
or maybe he just needed to get a second to be like
hear me roar for a guy that likes where comes
in it hits him up yeah yeah he needs to open
up that opportunity for him to be a hero that
was neat it was very neat and that was neat
i didn't expect such a teen drama show so it's
very teen drama with uh the discussion of bullying
in school i don't know what schools are like in
korea no no idea what it's like so sometimes i'm
like is that how things go okay maybe you know
yeah but in terms of what we're getting i think
it's i'm interested to see how it all ultimately
coalesces together because sometimes the
rhythm can be a tad off to me where like some
of the horror can feel like sporadic yeah and
then like oh we're really slowing down a lot
now yeah and but the thing is on the flip side
i really like that because that's why i just want
to see how it ultimately unfolds because um the i
like that you're really taking the time to build
the dynamics build the relationships build the
chemistry with a bunch of these people at school
like you're not you're seeing the faculty faculty
the faculty
you're seeing yeah all the students and such
and um and then of course there's a lot of
themes uh and allegories dealing with like
watched allegories it's just very it's it's
very heavy-handed uh the whole thing with bullying
going on in the school as well and uh so i wanna
more than just seeing like i hope this bullet gets
taken down i i wanna see how the themes is they
treat it with such heavy subject matter like you
have that one student who's straight up being like
you know sexually assaulted and then she's willing
to commit suicide by the end like these are these
are very heavy topics and um i don't know maybe
she'll find something to live for by the end
but she'll become a badass zombie killer yeah
yeah validation through there because you have
like a very serious subject matter you're
exploring and then on the opposite spectrum
there's almost this like level of camp with
the zombie stuff you know yeah it's it it
feels like very like like i said earlier the
music has this like psychedelic influence to it
it's like boom boom boom boom like this build
yeah like this percussion build reminded some
of the music cues in like a 28 days later
or something like that yeah yeah but it's
more uh when it comes to the zombie stuff it
it it feels like a lot more sci-fi infused
and like they they get like real trippy with
it shots so some some like looking forward to
seeing how the marriage of all these elements
comes together if it if it ultimately does
because yeah it's like sometimes the the
rhythm can feel a little bit off to me
because i like i really like i i always want
my horror to do the character building and do
the relationship stuff and i think because of
the fact that it's a zombie show we know that
zombies are coming and he had the anxiety
of like [ __ ] guys zombies you know and
then it's like oh the anxiety is built okay now
we're cutting to hang out with these people here
yeah yeah yeah and uh but by the end of it you
know it is it is pretty exciting stuff so i am
curious to see how how ultimately the pace unfolds
but yeah what'd you think of the for first episode
it's pretty solid it's a saw pilot i'm definitely
interested to see how it goes yeah i really
enjoyed it i think that was the sort of most
unique thing here was the way that they presented
the story with all the different scenes and the
juxtaposition of yeah what's a normal day like
for all these people versus the outbreak that's
about to turn everything upside down and i agree
i i feel like i'm going to need a minute to let it
sort of matriculate through my brain in terms of
how it feels as an overall pacing experience but
i do appreciate that geography of like okay this
thing is breaking out while everything's you know
normal in various other pockets of the school and
i feel like that gives it an interesting you know
like every zombie movie seeks to put you there
in the action but i feel like that is a kind
of interesting way to do it that doesn't really
feel like any other zombie movie or show i
have seen up until this point uh because you
know you start out in a pretty intense place
of just character anguish and then immediately
you're also given this piece of context where it
has something to do or it's coinciding with the
start of this outbreak that has some originating
connective tissue to the you know science teacher
the bio teacher and then you know seeing how those
two things really stay parallel even across all
the moments like for so it's interesting like the
characters and i feel like this is a good thing
because it is kind of real it's like there's
nobody who seems just like oh they're the good
guy or protagonist character of the show right
now like everyone's you know they're all kids
they're all a bit rascally and stuff like that you
know they're all just kind of of a normal day of
school and so i feel like that's an exciting
thing too is maybe there will be some coming
of age and some real sort of character revealing
through these kids as they undergo this horrific
nightmare experience and uh it was like sarcastic
ribbing but i would say like the mate the first
the guy with the the neighbor i think he's like
a good i think he's like they just sarcastically
rip each other yeah i don't think there's or
like they jest but i don't think there's any
like if there are a lot of characters just kind
of mean yeah yeah totally and between the two of
them i i do appreciate yeah it's like the two of
them and maybe the other guy who she's crushing on
and stuff like that you know that's a former betty
yeah that'll become a love triangle or something
yeah uh but yeah you know like yeah the way that
they do have that sort of you know sibling-esque
ribbing like i like that approach to the character
for some reason these didn't feel quite as
and this isn't even coming from hollywood so
i don't want to use the word like holly woody
but you know like they didn't feel like movie
characters so much as they felt like yeah you're
just kind of in a school and everybody's you know
doing the same run-of-the-mill stuff that they're
always doing and this is kind of how they have
their rapport together and so yeah there's sort of
uh i don't know exactly what the right word is but
i like the way they drew the characters alongside
you know the chaos that's breaking loose true
i think the way it's shot too when it comes to
the zombie moments are really cool they use a lot
of these one takes oh yeah it's like for the most
part steady cam it's really steady like the first
shot has this really good opener and that really
establishes your mood and your theme of it like
it starts off on the like emergency red cross
and it seems like there's gonna be some biblical
allegories as well flat out beats his son with a
bible yeah and he's the saves with the shot of
it circling in it and i i do and then of course
like the the ending uh towards the end too when
the camera is moving soon enough from the school
like you have this interesting set of where like
they're getting you acquainted with like here's
the layout of the sets yeah where chaos can ensue
and i like i like a lot of the shots that they use
here and they're very very clear and they don't
rely heavily on like some shots are very like the
chaotic jittery [ __ ] that we often associate
with fast-running zombies now yeah but that
it's not overly reliant on that which i i think is
impressive um and it does have a quirkiness about
it yes which was something i wasn't i i don't
i didn't see a trailer for this so i don't know
anything about it i'd like to walk into this
go wow this is pretty uh it's pretty different
than what i agree when i hear like korean zombie
show but but it has that like soap opera korean
you know what it is i think of what why that
rhythm could feel a little bit off is because
we're still getting to while i find the characters
interesting and we're still getting to know the
characters the zombie stuff is the most familiar
and the thing you're probably looking forward to
most when hearing about this show so my high level
of interest tends to be in the zombie stuff yeah
so i'm like super invested and interested
whenever there's like crazy song and then it cuts
to the other stuff and i think like so maybe
it's not even a pacing problem but it's more of
um or i don't know actually but in the moment
it's like but i'm way more interested right now
with that zombie thing than i am and hearing
them like talk about their crushes right yeah
yeah yeah is the chicken good yeah you build it
up i think too it goes against formula in a lot
of ways with how they cut around because usually
it would be like you you get the characters a
queen and dotted dawn and then like the last
20 minutes then the outbreak starts we're crazy
for just 23 minutes as opposed to stop yeah it's
like you introduce them side by side and you let
the outbreak be building from the beginning
true true yeah but it's a good show uh so
far right now what we're getting is good yeah i
don't know what this i'm still still curious to
know like what the split was on like community
posts as if it was if that had to do with the
looking at the comments i was like yeah i'm
like is it actually the other side is it the
fact that people don't really like the show or
was it the comments that i saw of like people
who didn't actually watch it mm-hmm like
i just hit no because i just said because
i want i have another show i want you to start
up this one yeah yeah not this yeah for sure um
but yeah it's cool it's cool stuff it's cool
stuff still got eleven more episodes to go
got one little context clue just a quick shout
out to gwenever call over at the patreon who said
you know that that partly what they're gonna dig
on at least in terms of like the overall there's
there's a ferry accidents the seawall ferry
accident that brought up a bunch of you know uh
questions in korea and whatnot about you know
the sort of culture of obedience and that was
something that i thought was sort of starting
to uh you know show its head with the adult
characters and if there's one thing i would guess
it's that probably because they're all like the
adults throughout this episode are constantly
sitting around like we should have dealt with
this internally well don't call the police well
we gotta yeah so like i feel like probably the
one thing i would imagine they'll start to examine
with the adult characters would be yeah how do we
approach the spread of information and the
spread of protocols that our society puts out
versus actually addressing a crisis for what it is
you know yeah yeah but uh yeah interesting about
the only clues thanks for that gwenevere thanks
gwenevere it's a cool clue to have yeah all right
guys we'll keep a lookout for one in reaction
to the next episode is up i'll try to get up in
a couple days that's why you guys subscribe and
stay notified look out for that notification bell
ignore the ones that you're not interested in and
then click on the ones you're interested in that's
how it works yeah selection process use your
judgment all right guys we will talk to you soon